can you take us back to that day in 1986
it was what Landover Maryland right what
were you thinking before you got in a
car how much planning had you done
before you drove to the Capitol Center
well heavy metal parking lot is the
title that kind of these many years
later still is pretty much front and
center in my my resume and body of work
and it was a collaboration between
myself and John Hine somebody who I have
become friends with and started working
with we both were aspiring documentary
filmmakers but this was around in mid
well 1986 and our mid 20s we struck upon
this idea to go interview metal fans
heavy metal fans in their natural
environment if you will which was the
parking lot I'm a concert arena and in
our case the local concert arena was the
capital Center in Maryland outside of
Washington DC
you know just your standard concrete
concert you know multi-purpose arena
which had sporting events and concerts
among other things but it happened to be
Judas Priest it was a beautiful spring
night May 31st 1986 and we just went
there with the public access cameras
that I had I was running a studio
community television studio so John and
I took right these cameras professional
cameras three quarter-inch cameras
pneumatic tape and clunky by today's
standards but professional at the time
and we just went out into the parking
lot of the Capitol Center paid our way
and like any concert goer but instead
brought this camera this equipment
camera and recording deck out and
started wandering the parking lot
interviewing anybody who came came up to
us we didn't have to you know solicit
much input they were all very
accommodating and it was a real novelty
I mean who would have thought to see you
wouldn't have expected to see a camera
crew wandering a concert parking lot but
the idea really came from John Hine he
was the one who
had the idea I had the equipment and we
basically we went in I paid driving my
78 Bonneville in like any other concert
go or paid our $5 admission to Park
parking paid our fee to park and just uh
that's how it started and did you or
John have a list of questions beforehand
or were you almost like winging it like
just let's just see what happens we
could get kicked out bingo ha ha we
actually what happened was we were we
had an idea that it would be colorful
and entertaining but we also were we
were not metal fan wouldn't excuse me we
were not metalheads we were we were not
we were familiar with the music and
familiar with the culture because it was
very much very popular even if the song
even if the music wasn't getting played
on on hit radio it was still part of the
culture hair metal heavy metal could
fill concert arenas even without hits so
to speak so it was all around you but we
were not we were the farthest thing from
metalheads
but we were very curious and that was I
think really at the root of this we were
just going to kind of wing it and see
what we got
wandering around with this camera and
microphone and we had no agenda
we had no you know we had no interest in
putting words in people's mouths
we were not you know trying to make you
know we were not trying to make fun of
anybody we just wanted to see what would
happen and and it all just kind of
unfolded a very a real and/or you know
real sense and you know organic sense
and anthropological sense I don't know
all these people have said things about
it that were not intended when we made
it
but we're very grateful to now be
talking about it almost 30 years later
and so how much time did you actually
spend in that parking lot once you park
that car that Bonneville what was the
time frame we were in the parking lot
for two hours we probably rolled in at 4
o'clock let's see the concert would have
started at 7
I don't even know 8 maybe that seems
kind of late but I remember us being in
the concert parking lot for about two
hours because we only had at a little
over an hour we had four tapes for 20
minute tapes so that's an hour and 20
minutes and you know once we filled
those up we were done so you know was a
very low shooting ratio and which is
kind of unbelievable even to me right
now but you know we only had four
surplus pneumatic tapes they weren't
even brand new tapes we just took them
from the the stock pile of the cable
company and so all of this is anything
it's not how I would do it now do a lot
different brand new tape a lot bigger
shooting ratio would get a lot more
content but at the time we were it we
just struck gold with just that our and
some it's hour and 10 20 minutes not
even I don't think we even filled up the
fourth tape a lot of the raw footage was
us just kind of you know you we we went
back and looked at the original tapes
some years later and to see what we had
left on the cutting room floor and
there's not much most of what we got
that was really great what went into the
finished piece so what was the
prevailing commentary from these people
I know they talked about Madonna
punk-rock Ronald Reagan but what was the
underlying theme was it just we're here
to party were young we're kind of
carefree we love Judas Priest we love
Rob Halford well I think that's it was
really just you know like I've been a
concert goer I mean I remember what it
was like to you know be passionate and
excited about music or whatever music
had was you know my you know the
soundtrack that I rallied around so I
knew you know you weren't expecting any
kind of great
you know Nobel laureate commentary from
any anybody out in an environment like
this and then if you add you know
alcohol or stronger then it's even more
unlikely to have any kind of disc
beyond just what people were saying
which was you know their excitement
about their music the favorite music and
and what they were there to do that
night it was really a kind of tribal and
and and I one of my favorite reviews of
heavy metal parking lot was around the
time not long after we we started
showing it this was a local reviewed in
the Washington City paper and it said
that the the filmmakers don't reveal
themselves to be any brighter than the
people that are being interviewed which
was great it was totally you know which
was I thought perfect because we really
weren't asking anything more you know
who are you here to see tonight you know
there wasn't anything or are you here to
party or you having a good time you know
and then basically everybody just took
it from there so we were kind of one in
the same in that sense
you